und nun aus gegebenem anlass zu einem
klassischen edgar wallace schocker die
toten hirne von london
diese woche sind wir alle dem
sogenannten no deal drexhage ein stück
näher gekommen leider auch im sechsten
anlauf hat ist das britische unterhaus
nicht geschafft einen weg aus der
sackgasse zu finden noch hoffen zwar
manche auf ein zweites referendum aber
was würde das bringen manche wollen dem
break cit manchen ist es war ein split
fifty fifty eigentliche und sagt wenn er
noch mal ein wahl geben würde dann wird
es 50 50 in der andere richtung gehen
[Applaus]
man könnte auch sagen theresa may führt
mit 0 zu melden
immerhin will das unterhaus einen no wax
it verhindern sagen sie
gleichzeitig fordern die abgeordneten
aber neue verhandlungen wozu die
eu-geführte 10.000 mal nein gesagt hat
liebe engländer erklärt man dass diese
beiden beschlüsse schließen sich aus
wien
weil sie nicht ryan air und beinfreiheit
das geht nicht es geht mich klar die
irland frage ist komplex aber der
sogenannte back stopped war doch maze
vorschlag man fragt sich was machen die
da eigentlich in ihrem parlament die
ganze zeit hier alle highlights vom
dienstag
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bunte
oder und der wut oder unter
alter sehen wir in der brennpunktschule
das erwarten sind so geht debattenkultur
nicht über uns in diesem baldrian
bundestag
leider haben die engländer aber selber
gar keine idee wie das eigentlich
funktionieren soll also nicht in der
zollunion bleiben aber keine
grenzkontrollen zwischen irland und
nordirland kein schimmer das darf sich
jetzt schon wieder die arme eu überlegen
du hast grenzt doch an braig duelle
belästigung ernsthaft jetzt ist er 18
uhr auf die machen in einer tour ihre
probleme zu unsern die deutschen und die
eu wollen dass wir etwas unterschreiben
das dazu führen könnte dass nordirland
vom rest des vereinigten königreichs
getrennt wird ich frage mich auch
deutsche politiker es akzeptieren würden
wenn ein teil deutschlands anders
verwaltet würde ja ich weiß heute haben
bayern sachsen etwas aus
[Applaus]
heute ein publikum voller separatisten
verstehen
gleichzeitig ziehen immer mehr firmen
ihr kapital aus großbritannien ab in der
trans sprache sind die engländer auf dem
besten weg zum entschuldigung drecksloch
land ja sorry
nach neuesten zahlen ist die britische
autoindustrie zum beispiel im letzten
jahr total eingebrochen um meine
lieblings meldung aus dieser woche
mcdonald's die firma mcdonald's hat
mitgeteilt bei einem notar exit wäre die
qualität ihrer produkte in gefahr
und das ist noch nicht alles wie agra so
weit das auge reicht diese britische
internet apotheke rüstet sich für den
ernstfall
viele im land beginnen das hamstern aus
angst vor dem harten drexhage es macht
sinn eine fabrik sind ohne viagra
schwierig ich glaube dafür nehmen sie
uns den grimme preis wieder weg so und
dabei hätte frau mehr regierung so viele
andere baustellen so viele echte
probleme laut einem uno-bericht leben
millionen britischer kinder in armut und
die gruppe der englischen working poor
wird auch immer größer und deutschland
undenkbar ich höre gerade meine damen
und herren es gibt wohl breaking news zu
endlosen drechsel krise
ok und zwar tut sich was auf der
französischen seite des eurotunnels für
uns vor ort in calais ist die kollegin
birte schneider
frau schneider umfasst gerade was
passiert denn da gerade das kann ich
ihnen sagen
die eu hat hier endlich den verdammten
eurotunnel zu ende aus feierabend
die mauer die mauer zu wir schaffen
jetzt fakten weil die nicht zu potte
kommen auf ihrer verregneten misst insel
wie in dem gedicht ein korb voller rosen
ein zärtlicher kuss lädt uns am arsch
wir machen jetzt schluss ja ist leider
noch nicht ganz fertig da kommen immer
noch britische flüchtlinge ganz schwer
zu integrieren
ja gleichzeitig wollen vereinzelter
afrikaner trotz allem nach england gehen
da nicht hinweise scheiße das ist mir
jetzt frau kollegin doch ein bisschen zu
viel pech ich kann das nicht mehr hören
schon beim wort brachse kritik pickel
praxis klingt die katzenfutter von lidl
über einem jahr verhandlungen jetzt
wollen die mit uns nochmal über irland
reden wir wollen aber nicht bedeute bei
irland reden
never etwa auf guck mal oma backen
gemacht auch die biege
bis klar
[Applaus]
die warme mahlzeit am tag sind halt was
feines da drüben rocken die ersten jahr
schon die ersten lebensmittel wenn er
hunger hat könnt ihr euch after eight
überbacken
naja gut wird irgendein deal wäre schon
wichtig für beide seien wählte es reicht
jetzt wir können keine zur junioren aber
schon über eine zollunion man engländer
man kann auch in der eu sein und
trotzdem ein egoistisches arschloch so
wie wir gegen kein eu land laufen so
viele vertragsverletzungsverfahren wie
geht unsere verguckte energiewende haben
wir vorher mit keinem europäischen land
abgestimmt wenn es passt scheißen wir
auf eu regeln
das ist die deutsche lösung sich zur ehe
bekennen aber flatrate im swinger-club
davon könnte eine scheibe abschneiden
der jugend katar pins fromm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
genau
mir macht es wichtig schon klar
man kann hier von uns lernen frau
schneider aus meiner oder man verschiebt
den ganzen dreck sind doch noch mal
quatsch morgen machen wir hier dicht und
vivaz hab's dir gesagt wird schneider
mal darunter
[Applaus]
ja es ist schon die frage der woche wie
kann man diese briten vielleicht doch
noch zur vernunft bringen
da hilft wahrscheinlich nur noch die
schärfste waffe der eu unser deutscher
haushaltskommissar günther don't [ __ ] is
my back stopped oettinger ja wenn der es
nicht schafft schafft es keiner
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt ein brite
und sie versuchen mich zu überzeugen
dass ich doch in der eu bleiben und dann
jetzt mal richtig mit herzblut gemacht
einen klugen prexl im unterhaus in der
öffentlichkeit denn das chaos würde euch
gewaltigen und uns auch großen schalten
zu finden soll ich jetzt auch so
reagieren wie ein normaler brite
entscheiden sie foto in einer kneipe in
stuttgart ab und sind zum teil auch dna
oder lass mich in ruhe könnte man es
vielleicht so machen man zieht den br-
exit durch und dafür schließt sich die
eu großbritannien an
die briten wollten hier raus also
wollten sich von uns entfernen umso
wichtiger dank meines erachtens nicht
wirklich wahrscheinlich
ich glaube eher dass sie die 15 jahren
eine neue generation hat briten den
erneuten eintritt beschließen wird sind
wir deutschen vielleicht auch gegen den
dreck weil wir wissen wie teuer so der
wiedervereinigung irgendwann mal werden
kann
nein wir deutsche in der mehrzahl wollen
die deutschen dass die briten geblieben
wären
und wir gucken auch gerne die hochzeiten
wenn ich sie vielleicht wir haben in
einer demokratie zu akzeptieren dass ein
referendum mit einer mehrheit
entschieden hat rauszugehen
gut ist es ja eine freie entscheidung
mit dem kopf gegen die wand zu laufen
hier habe ich bin einmal die jetzt heiß
berührt macht das nehmen ja ja ja ich
würde gern noch da es ja doch
wahrscheinlich ist dass die briten die
eu verlassen mit ihnen das letzte
interview auf englisch führen
also ich kann mich sehr gut nur ist so
blöd mit design ist auf englisch zu
reden
ich kann sehr schlecht englisch deswegen
bin ich froh dass sie so können ich kann
es gut aber ich habe das nicht lust beim
deutschen fernsehen zweiten deutschen
fernsehen englisch zu reden aber wir
sind auch viel auf youtube schön feucht
was würden sie theresa may für einen
tipp geben das nicht meine aufgabe
ich habe viel respekt sie tanzt ja sogar
auch sehr gut ist ihre sache nicht an
sie auch was kann sowohl wiener walzer
foxtrott wie rock'n roll haben wir
diesen worten zurück ins studio
westerwald